well it's not that easy being creepy
porn lawyer these days there is the
legal problem he faces likely he's gonna
head to the big house for extortion but
relatively speaking that's not the
biggest problem the bigger problem for
CPL is that nobody seems to remember him
just last night the all-time greatest
champion on Jeopardy was asked to name
the creepy porn lawyer and he couldn't
do it watch this
this lawyers star rose while reppin
stormy Daniels but fell after he was
accused of trying to extort millions
from Nike in 2019 his name quickly
forgotten obviously ouch
but Alex Trebek knowledge of although he
is wasn't exactly precisely right it's
not that his name is forgotten it's the
people never knew his name in the first
place
jeopardy wanted some obscure other name
for the creepy porn lawyer but if you
watched this show you know he goes by
only one title though who is this creepy
porn lawyer well the world's creepiest
porn lawyer has gotten very famous
recently we mentioned the creepy porn
lawyer you just been hearing about the
one you've seen on TV recently
threatening people you may have heard us
cover the creepy porn lawyer it's all
about the creepy porn lawyer
hashtag creepy porn lawyer please stick
around the creepy porn lawyer is back
that creepy porn lawyer is back that's
the bad news
picture yourself standing in your
kitchen at night getting one last glass
of water from the kitchen sink and you
look at into the backyard and there's
creepy porn lawyer we invited the creepy
porn lawyer on to this show
creepy porn lawyer great to see you